- It's weird in here.
We'll do a root
canal right here.
Pull that shit out.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
("Follow Me" by Anthony Russo)
- [Gary] Yo.
What up, my man?
Just heading to
new business pitch.
Hey GaryVee here on
the streets reporting.
Monday morning, doing my thing.
Nice and cloudy.
Is exactly when people
don't want to do it.
I love when people
I love that.
Forgot about DRock.
We'll figure it out.
I'm a flexible CEO.
(camera shuttering)
- [Man] How's it going? Good.
- [Alex] It's all audio.
Remember this? We did
it last time, it was video.
- [Woman] GaryVee became
a prolific investor and
venture capitalist investing in
companies including Facebook,
Twitter, Tumblr,
Uber and Birchbox.
So I'm gonna jump on
one of the things you said,
Facebook.
- Yes.
- [Woman] So you were an
early adopter of Facebook Live.
Can you tell us a little bit
more the opportunities you
see with live streaming?
- [Gary] You know it's funny
that I didn't mention live at
all in my opening rant.
And I think that's an indicator.
I like live.
I think live is hard.
I think for most of the brands
and personalities in the world,
live is an
extremely difficult format.
I think it's sexy.
People are talking about it
but I just wish that people
understood how to make
Facebook commercials and videos.
These one, two, three minute
videos around your business,
whether B2B or B2C that
would drive your results.
You know, it's kind of
like you asking me like,
"Hey Gary, why aren't
"seven-year-olds thinking
about driving?"
And because I'm still worried
about can they ride a bike.
Before people worry about
mastering the hardest medium of
all which is live video,
I like them to figure
out just video on Facebook.
Heck, just pictures on
Facebook so I like live.
I think it's
really personality driven.
I think it has to
bring a lot of value.
I think people have to
think in morning TV show,
late night TV show,
drive time radio dynamics.
What does a brand really do?
I think some of the stunt stuff
can be fun but live is a very
competitive,
very difficult thing.
You're asking for somebody to
give you their attention on
your time, not on their time.
And so, that is a very, outside
of live sports and the biggest
events in the world,
live is a real challenge.
You have to really bring value
and truth is I don't think most
businesses small or large
have even figured out how to
provide value in their content,
let alone their live strategy
and so intuitively
I don't even focus on it.
I canceled those next two
meetings (inaudible)
back to the (inaudible) meeting.
- [Maribel] Reached
out to director,
Denise Soler Cox.
Turned out she's
a huge fan of yours.
- [Gary] As she should be.
- She stood in line for one of
your books with her baby who was
not even a year old.
And so she like freaked out
when I reached out to her.
And she'd offered to come and
do a director's screening for us
if she got an hour of your time
and that potentially making the
feature length
version of this film.
So that's who
you're meeting with.
- I recognize that the
people that dislike me have
insecurities of their own.
And I actually
genuinely have empathy for them.
- [Denise] Uh-huh.
- Do you know bad
I feel for bad people?
Like if somebody draws a
swastika or pulls off somebody's
religious clothes
or hates black people,
I feel bad for them.
They lost.
- [Denise] Mhmmm.
- They lost in life.
- Of course, I feel bad for
the person the crime's being
committed on,--
- [Denise] Mhmmm.
- but I feel bad
for the other person.
They're a loser.
- [Denise] Mhmmm.
- Like you've lost.
- [Denise] Right.
- There's nothing
you can do to beat me.
- [Denise] Mhmmm.
- Good always beats evil.
It's how we're still here.
- [Denise] Mhmmm.
Thank you so much.
- Nice meeting you.
- [Amara] Am I (inaudible)
by sitting in this chair?
- [Gary] You can
do whatever you want.
You can do whatever you want.
- Thanks for taking the time.
- My pleasure, man.
Happy to be here.
- Yeah.
So Dave told me a lot about you.
I really didn't
know much until recently.
- Yep.
- But Dave was telling
me you love the music--
- Yep.
- I'm not sure, I'm with Russ.
- I'm aware.
- Yeah, so...
When I realized what
you guys had going on,
there's so many similarities
between how you
guys grew the families.
- [Gary] Well, it's one of
the reasons when I first got,
you guys have been
on him for a while.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] You know and I kept
hearing it in the background and
then finally had time to listen
to some music over the holidays
and I was reading, you know, it
was fun because Spotify did a
good job at integrating genius.
I really enjoyed that.
So I was reading.
I'm obsessed,
if I was to meet Rusty,
only thing I'd want to talk to
him about for 20 minutes,--
- [Amara] Uh-huh.
- would be his grandfather.
- [Amara] Ah.
- 'Cause I'm an entrepreneur.
- [Amara] Yeah.
- You know, that
story and that, yeah,
that narrative that
he puts out there--
- [Amara] Mhmmm.
- and the whole,
all I do is hustle.
If I was an artist,
I'd put out a song a day.
Forget about a week.
I want to put it out
every day if I could.
- [Amara] What we realized
was, the reason why most artists
don't realize it is 'cause
it happened super recently.
2014, yes Soundcloud, Spotify
all these things were available
but the user base hadn't arrived
the same way that they have now.
- [Gary] There's also economics
in not putting out free music.
Mix tapes was a love-hate thing.
The labels have no interest
in you putting out free music.
- [Amara] Absolutely.
- They're not monetizing it.
Absolutely.
- [Amara] Absolutely.
So when we started putting
out the song a weekly basis,
we realized yeah, the internet
moves so fast (snaps fingers)
that one week is
almost not enough time.
You need another song right away
and that's the best marketing
for the previous song as well.
- [Gary] It's more at-bats.
- [Amara] Exactly.
More shots to--
- Literally the way I
told my one friend who's
like terrible at getting girls.
I'm like, "You know what?
"Go completely unemotional and
"just say hello to
every one of them."
- [Amara] Facts.
- It's gonna
work out eventually.
("The City" by Bazanji)
Borman needs a job?
I think we can.
Like as crazy as that sounds.
It's weird in here.
We'll do a root
canal right here.
Pull that shit out.
The reason I love to do these
meetings is when you're young
and you want
something, you know,
you can get
clouded on the reality.
You are massively highly rated
and you're very much on the hot,
young rookie path not the
we don't see where
this guy fits path.
- [Man 2] Cool.
- [Gary] As long as they kind
of understand those core four or
five things that we all have to
have which is this is the kind
of work we want to do.
This is where we track
people's attention and
we care about that.
And then how we
treat each other.
- Yeah.
- I think the world doesn't
think that you should email a
CEO and have this conversation.
- [Woman 2] Mhmmm.
- Our world does and
it's hard to like fight
against the whole world.
- Yeah.
- And so I never get
disappointed anymore if
somebody's been here seven years
and still is scared or confused
or curious, I get it
now but I'll never waiver.
- Yeah.
- The biggest
challenge a leader has
is to get the people that
work with them to understand
that they work for them,
not the other way
around and to build trust and
so I'm feverish about that.
I'm so obsessed with it but
it's very difficult thing to
accomplish 'cause it's
not how the world works.
Yeah, that could
make a lot of sense.
What excites me is that I
want to fucking rule the world.
And when you want
to rule the world,
everything's in play, nothing's
out of bounds and you've proven
a lot to me which
creates even more opportunity.
That's it.
So I'm not
really crippled by it.
I'm giving you the binary,
you're in the family and I doubt
that we won't be able to figure
out shit for the next 50 years,
let alone five.
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- And in a world where I think
it's a real win to like the next
two or three
steps even in this path,
it doesn't make me feel like
oh shit if we don't figure
something out next
six months, it's over.
- [Man 3] No.
- And so that makes
me to be very frank,
very calm.
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- In a world where
I have that in other places.
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- Yeah, man.
You're a young man.
Obviously, we
have a young company.
Hang with me with 60 and
70-year-olds who on fire
the way you and I are.
If you start taking your career
into a macro at 64-years-old,
double your age today, I'm
working with those people every
day and they want it.
That's around the age
I plan on buying the Jets.
Like you're whole life.
Literally from the day
you were born to today,
like you know how
much work that is?
You know how much
learnings that is?
This is, I don't think
people get it, brother.
Do you know I don't
think people get it?
I don't know if I fully got it.
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- To be quite frank.
You know?
I did but more blindly, now it's
more black-and-white and
it's about to get color.
Sure, I'm very
comfortable with that.
I'm comfortable with two or
three people being in that
position but she's
probably the closest to that.
- [Man 4] Okay.
Okay, cool.
That's good to know.
("Live Forever" by Bugus)
I'm in such a
great fucking mood.
I can just feel it happening.
Wish you guys
the best life ever.
So much fucking opportunity.
Go get yours,
please go get yours.
("Live Forever" by Bugus)